[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
ya está conmigo en el estudio en el gran
don dani bienvenida buena mañana de
miércoles ya estamos a mitad de esta
semana informativa el nuevo ministro de
finanzas británico llegó prometiendo una
reducción de impuestos así de raúl muy
buenos días y feliz miércoles para usted
también en medio de una cascada de
emisiones en eeuu en downing street de
nadie mensaje a we pasado el ministerio
de educación al de finanzas la respuesta
del mercado no se hizo esperar este
martes y miércoles la libra esterlina ha
caído frente al dólar a su nivel más
bajo desde marzo de 2020 cuando inició
el confinamiento por la pandemia en su
nuevo cargo zawi dijo en una entrevista
que se centraría en controlar la
inflación que ya supera el 9% anual
y el primer ministro quiere asegurarse
de que tengamos disciplina fiscal
comparto ese enfoque con él porque si
permitimos que la inflación se salga de
control es muy dañino para esas mismas
personas a las que estamos tratando de
ayudar hoy con esos 37 mil millones de
libras de ayuda durante los próximos 12
meses pero por supuesto buscaré de donde
más puedo asegurarme de que la economía
siga siendo competitiva y dinámica con
nuestros vecinos europeos y por supuesto
también con el resto del mundo estamos
viendo entonces esas imágenes de lo que
ha sido esta huelga de trabajadores del
sector ferroviario en francia hablemos
también de eso claro raúl en este paro
participan tres de los cuatro sindicatos
del operador ferroviario estatal de
francia sncf y lo hacen justo un par de
días antes de que comiencen oficialmente
las vacaciones de verano hasta el
momento en promedio se reporta la
cancelación del 30 por ciento de los
trenes en las líneas principales aunque
las rutas internacionales operan con
normalidad esta huelga se suma a
movimientos similares del sector de la
energía también del transporte aéreo
todos con demandas muy parecidas
y todos los días cuando vas al
supermercado o cada semana cuando tan
que has tu auto tienes facturas que
pagar y cuando tu salario no aumenta eso
te golpea duro la gente se enfoca en las
huelgas y las consecuencias para los
viajeros por supuesto cuando quieres
tomar tu tren y tu tren está allí no
estarán muy contentos pero entonces
deberíamos quizás ir más allá y eso
significa que el principal problema en
francia no es nuestra huelga son los
salarios que no aumentan los salarios
que no corresponden al aumento del costo
de la vida bueno han y llegamos con una
noticia lamentables porque murió el
secretario general de la opep con 76
raúl se llama mohammad o se llamaba
mohammed barkindo el nigeriano de 63
años un veterano de la industria
petrolera terminaba su mandato de seis
años a finales de este mes en el puesto
más alto de la organización de países
exportadores de petróleo su figura había
recobrado mayor importancia en los
últimos años en los que tuvo que
afrontar raúl los momentos más
turbulentos de la historia reciente
primero con la pandemia que desplomó la
demanda de crudo y llevó los precios a
terreno inclusive negativo y ahora con
la guerra en ucrania presionando cada
vez más al mercado para liberar barriles
y así ayudar a bajar los altos precios
horas antes de su muerte
barkindo había inaugurado una cumbre
energética en abuya la capital nigeriana
en su último discurso expresó que la
industria del petróleo y del gas está
bajo asedio y que se tambalea por las
enormes pérdidas de inversiones de los
últimos años danielle indicadores
económicos en europa y fuertes ganancias
lideradas justamente por londres en
donde la respuesta de los mercados no se
ha hecho esperar a esta cascada de
dimisiones la bolsa de londres sube casi
17 por ciento y la libra esterlina cae
frente al dólar a su nivel más bajo
desde marzo de 2020 cuando inició el
confinamiento por la pandemia ahora las
acciones asiáticas cayeron en su mayoría
el miércoles después de un comercio
tibio en wall street en la jornada
anterior en medio de preocupaciones
desde luego sobre una recesión global y
que nos trae como cifra del día entre 5
millones y 8 millones de dólares raúl
que espera recibir la casa de subastas
sol / el esqueleto fosilizado de un
pariente del tiranosaurio rex que habitó
la tierra hace 76 millones de años será
subastado en nueva york el 28 de julio
hay que tener espacio en la casa para
poder poner ese fósil y me tengo que
salir yo para poder
darle gracias como siempre por toda la
información de economía nos vemos a
mañana con más por supuesto nosotros
vamos directo hasta parís